if this works this is the coolest thing
please work hi I'm Alexis and I'm the
senior food specialist here at tasty
last time my co-workers challenged me to
make a three-course meal using only a
coffee maker I'm expecting the worst but
let's see what they haven't stirred this
time okay the coffee maker was one thing
but I don't I what am I gonna do any
good chef should be able to cook with
with anything so luckily I have ironed
many clothes before but let's have a
look the first instruction is use iron
only for its intended use so don't try
this at home let's see what the Internet
has to say I just like who are these
people that test us out okay so this is
clearly a thing so I'm gonna see if I
can elevate clothing iron cooking just a
little bit for the first course I'm
gonna try to make a flatbread with like
a caramelized shallot dip so because my
dough for the flatbread needs to sit I'm
going to get started with that and I do
a really easy to ingredient flatbread
it's basically just Greek yogurt and
self-rising flour self-rising flour has
baking powder in it so you don't need to
add anything else do I like ironing I
mean I like ironing more than vacuuming
oh no you're gonna try to make me do
something with the back
this is going to rest for the second
course I'm going to make couscous and
lamb chops I'm going to marinate my lamb
chops so those gonna get really
flavorful and hopefully it'll mask the
fact that they are being cooked on iron
this is gonna be really simple it's just
garlic rosemary oil salt pepper it's
pretty classic so I got these tiny
little lamb chops and I thought like if
steak can be done so could a lamb chop
and you want them to be on the
medium-rare side so this actually could
work also if you look at the chopped
compared to the hair it's pretty perfect
so I'm just gonna plop these so that the
marinade sticks it better to it so these
are ready I'm going to wash my hands
cover them and refrigerate them thank
you for the refrigerator for dessert I'm
going to try to make a crepe cake but
I'm not using a recipe it's just like
feed an egg add a little flour add a
little milk and just do it until you get
a smooth consistency so my mom's Dutch
because I grew up with crepes or and
Dutch Monica she never followed a recipe
so yeah this is like my Sunday mornings
as a kid so I'm gonna do a few more
rounds but that should be good
I'm gonna put it on the linen setting
which is the hottest and see what
happens this feels weird
[Music]
what do I do I don't know I've never
done this before
well I don't know what's gonna work it's
cooking in a way okay
Oh God this is not gonna work but
[Music]
Jesse this pretty perfect it would be
really helpful to have pots and pans I
just wanna set up little butter
mold
it looks like it's cooking around the
very edge the crepes might be a little
thick but mine's a thick crepe it does a
bit rubbery it's weird but cooking okay
I'm gonna taste it I'm gonna try to make
it a little thinner
oh well that's going since technically a
hand mixer is an appliance which I
cannot use I'm hand whipping cream which
is not my favorite activity like the
brown it's happening Oh got one done
this is so weird that it's actually
making the coffeemaker seem like I'm
normal and easy I can't believe I'm
saying that I rather cook with a coffee
maker we get very reliant on our
appliances and tools and it's good to be
like you know we can make great food
wins very little okay I'm going to add a
little sugar look at that I mean this
whipped cream looks really pretty oh no
oh no it's soul okay put this all over
here
[Music]
okay it's sugar finally we're in it's
delicious
okay I've been making crepes for two
hours now but I think I can actually
start building it they're a little
lopsided so getting the cream even is
gonna be a journey you know I'm really
happy that the crepes actually worked I
was really skeptical when I first did
that parchment paper thing which was a
mistake this is the cutest thing I've
ever seen next step are the shallots I'm
just gonna keep it on linen that feels
like the best move since I can't use
real pots or pans I'm gonna try to
fashion one out of tinfoil it's like a
little shallot but I just want a burner
not asking for much just just a regular
partner so usually when I would make
this I would actually broil the onions
but let's see how this goes oh the sound
is good while those are doing the thing
I can get the rest ready it's really
easy sour cream mayonnaise a little time
for some extra flavor adding the lemon
here for some acidity to lemon zest
so the shallots are starting to become a
little aromatic they're getting some
browning which looks really great but I
don't think they're gonna get deeply
caramelized and I think for this just a
little golden brown if I can get that
that'll be fine I mean I think this is
the problem with cooking rhythm iron you
can't get really really high heat and
you're so limited by like linen cotton
Wolf's
my dough for the flatbread is more than
ready
so my deal with the flatbread is that I
can make it really thin and then it'll
have a better chance of cooking through
and crispy enough okay this is very thin
so I'll just put it on if this works
this is the coolest thing please work
I'm gonna roll out a few more I really I
don't know I mean the coffee maker is
really hard but since then I've just
been like dreaming of all these other
things I could make and this feels like
the new frontier it's starting to bubble
do you see it
[Music]
okay it's the tiniest tiniest Fleck of
browning I just need like a few round
spots and then I can flip it there are
brown spots thank you I'm just gonna put
the dip into the bowl I'm gonna add a
few chives on top just for a bit of
extra color put the flap right next to
it and we're done
I'm gonna move on to the couscous I
think I'm gonna use a measuring cup and
heat the water on top of the iron so
usually when you make couscous well
always when you make couscous if you
want to bring the water to a boil I
don't think that's quite going to happen
here but I think I can get the water to
be pretty warm I'm gonna add some peas
to the couscous just to give it some
more body it's honestly heating it up
really fast makes me think it won't come
to a full boil but that it could get
significantly hot so I'm gonna let it go
for a few minutes just chop some
scallions and parsley which can be mixed
with the couscous I just added a little
salt pepper and olive oil just to give
it a little more flavor as it goes okay
I think this is ready I'm gonna do it
[Music]
hopefully in five minutes this is will
have their fingers crossed I feel like
my confidence level is a solid six right
now just gonna fluff this couscous a
little but absorb the water not quite
cooked through I think I need to add
more water to it hope this isn't a
mistake hot they're super thin so
hopefully this is gonna help my cups see
if this works
I wonder if it's gonna get like that
kind of nice browned outside or if it's
just gonna look kind of gray okay
something's happening
it's not this little bit of brown kind
of slowly but surely I think maybe I
just need to let it
[Music]
okay it's gonna go like that
[Music]
let's take another peek
I mean it's cooked it's browned the
backsides a little gray to touch that up
but this side looks pretty good let's
see this Chris Koos
[Music]
it's cooked it's cooked oh my God thank
God
so I'm gonna add the couscous back to
the scallions parsley okay this little
chop is perfect until next and then good
to go I'm gonna wrap it up plate
everything I've texted one of my friends
Nikki and she's gonna come up and try
this but she doesn't know that I've made
it completely with an iron why are you
so nervous I don't know why I'm here
did you like make it in a vacuum cleaner
or something is this the appliance show
this is your first course there's a
flatbread and shout dip yeah delicious
[Laughter]
your second course is couscous with peas
and lamb chops Wow lamb chops it's a
little dry but let's do this what's on
this thing to move delicious hard on and
your third course isn't she's beautiful
this is only for me yeah it's only for
you go crazy on my case she's dead she
is dense
talofa okay so you're right this is the
appliance chef do you want to guess
there's something weird it's an iron you
ironed all of this
did you just well done
LEM intimidates me even when I have a
whole kitchen but you did it with just
an iron I'm gonna take this sure thank
you so much that took six hours a lot of
trial and error and defeat batches of
whipped cream but I did it it was really
cool and weird and I am excited and kind
of fear what's next
stay tuned
[Music]